Brazil's president jair bolsonaro the
Trump of the tropics has ravaged the
rainforest drummed up Division and
overseen a disastrous response to
covid-19
but bolsonaro outperformed expectations
in the first round of the presidential
election win or lose the runoff he and
his popular movement is not going away
so what does that mean for the future of
Brazil
foreign
[Music]
Brazil in Sao Paulo thousands of people
have gathered they're here to show their
support for one man
in his four years as president jair
bolsonaro has won a cult-like devotion
from his followers they call him Mito
myth or Legend is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bolsonaro swept to power in 2018.
by tapping into disillusionment with the
corrupt political establishment and
economic recession
he could portray himself as an outsander
as an anti-system candidate as a sort of
Maverick who who could save Brazil from
corruption from crypto politicians
in the four years since he's given a
megaphone to a growing conservative
climber in Brazil family
[Music]
a master of social media with millions
of followers online he's inspired
devotion among those who believe him
when he says his left-wing opponent
Louise Ignacio Lula de Silva is a crook
who might be in League with the Devil
he painted Lula as a corrupt and immoral
communist and for a lot of Brazilians
who were still very upset about the
massive lava Jato corruption Scandal
that came out in the government after
Lula and the economic recession that
happened around the same time these
people are really afraid of a return of
Lula and bolsonaro really tapped into
that in Congress he's backed by a
coalition of right-wing and center-right
parties that now control half of the
lower house and in the Senate they won
13 of the 27 seats contested in 2022
if Lula wins he's going to really
struggle to govern a lot of these
conservative parties are going to form a
staunch opposition to him and he's going
to have to negotiate with these more
kind of ideologically vacant
center-right parties on the other hand
if bolsonaro manages to win the election
having all of these new allies in
Congress will make it much easier for
him to push forward loosening of
environmental regulations and gun
restrictions
three groups form the Bedrock of
bolsonaro support gun holders
Evangelical Christians and farmers
expanding gun rights has been one of the
Hallmarks of bolsonaro's presidency his
tough rhetoric on Prime and his military
experience as a former Army Captain have
persuaded many Brazilians that he knows
what it takes to keep them safe
some of bolsonaro's strongest allies in
Congress belong to the pro-gun lobby
known as the bullet caucus
most of the members of this program
caucus are members of security forces
who've decided to run for office
Captain Jose Augusto Rosa is one of them
a member of the Sao Paulo military
police the congressman boasts a 14-year
friendship with president bolsonaro
please
um
[Music]
[Music]
this caucus is mostly related to people
who want to have their own guns because
they think that by having guns they are
able to attack whole urban violence or
rural violence or public security more
broadly you don't know
uh flexibility
is
[Music]
one of bolsonaro's first acts as
president was to sign an executive order
relaxing gun laws in essence helping to
arm his supporters
on his watch the ownership and import of
guns has risen rapidly
and the number of guns in private hands
has doubled to nearly 2 million
[Music]
many of Brazil's gun lovers live in
rural areas where bolsonaro's approach
to environmental regulations is also one
piece of court
the president's allies claim that his
policies walk a careful line
foreign
but having laws and enforcing them are
two different matters whilst bolsonaro
and his allies now present him to the
world as an environmental protector the
evidence from his presidency tells a
different story we have seen a massive
deregulation regarding environmental
loss and that of course benefits a kind
of predatory Agro business
producers who don't really care about
the environment and who have pushed a
very strong agenda and that of course
has an impact on the indigenous
populations as well because we have many
indigenous peoples living in protected
areas in Brazil
Vietnam
[Music]
deforestation rates in Brazil spiked
during bolsonaro's presidency
his refusal to enforce the law has
helped push parts of the Amazon closer
to what some scientists fear could be a
Tipping Point where the rainforest turns
into dry grassland
bolsonaro's presidency has brought
religion into politics too
nearly a third of Brazilians identifies
Evangelical
at the last election 70 of them voted
for bolsonaro
Evangelical pastors present him as a
protector of family values and leave
their congregations in no doubt what's
at stake should his opponents take power
foreign
the way bolsonaro has dealt with
Evangelical uh voters by by saying that
he's the only president in Brazil in the
history of Brazil who will be using God
he's the only president who really loves
evangelicals even though he himself is a
Catholic and by trying to bridge this
Catholic Protestant dividing the country
by presenting himself as a pen Christian
president bolsonaru is able to capture
the the the love and the support and the
Loyalty of these holders
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
has persuaded his supporters of another
higher truth that he represents the
authentic will of the people when courts
rule against him bolsonaro suggests
they're biased when the media criticize
him he dismisses them as Peddlers of
fake news
[Music]
many of his supporters now believe that
any institution that stands in his way
is wicked and must be challenged also
now keeps spitting his supporters
against political institutions because
well that's what populists generally do
they want to connect directly with
supporters with what they call the
people and they don't really want to get
caught by partisan or institutional
obstacles and bolsonaro did it very very
um frugally over the last four years the
fact that the polls really
underestimated both scenario's support
going into the first round is really
going to add feel to the flame of this
rhetoric that bolsonaro has that the
polls can't be trusted the Supreme Court
can't be trusted the voting machines
can't be trusted you might think that
because he ended up much further ahead
than people were saying that that would
sort of cause him to say oh actually the
voting machines are okay you know we
trust them them now but of course that's
not how populism works and instead he's
used this to even cast more doubt over
the whole system if bolsonaro wins he'll
be emboldened to chip away at Brazilian
institutions even more as it is his
supporters seem primed for victory
[Music]
bolsonaro has strongly hinted that he
won't accept the result if he loses many
of his well-armed supporters will
believe him if he cries fraud and some
may resort to violence bolsonaro and
Trump are words of the same feather if
also Noto loses the election the feeling
that I have is that we're gonna see
something along the lines of the capital
riot and it's unclear whether Brazil's
military police many of whom support
bolsonaro will stop them
this is a stress test for Brazil's
institutions for the Electoral
Institution
police for the Army even if Brazil does
manage to calm things down in the
streets among Bolson is supporters and
Lula manages to take office on January
1st without any problems bolsonarismo is
not going away
if bolsonaro loses he may continue to
lead a movement of people who think he
is the rightful president that doesn't
bode well for stability in Brazil nor
does the very real possibility that one
day he'll be back
I'm Sarah Maslin the Brazil
correspondent for The Economist to read
more of our Brazil election coverage
please click the link and don't forget
to subscribe